estéril 62 a favor 38 en contra la ley
está aprobada indian ahora el primer
estado de los eeuu en aprobar una
prohibición casi total del aborto desde
que se derogó robersis wait la cámara
mayoría republicana voto a favor de la
propuesta de ley del senado aprobando
las restricciones a la interrupción del
embarazo la prohibición que entra en
vigor el 15 de septiembre permitirá el
aborto sólo en casos de violación o
incesto siempre y cuando se realice
dentro de las 10 semanas después de la
fecundación sólo los hospitales podrán
realizar el procedimiento que significa
que todas las clínicas de aborto en el
estado perderán sus licencias indiana
empezó a debatir leyes de aborto más
estrictas poco después de junio cuando
la corte suprema- voto para eliminar la
protección constitucional al
procedimiento los habitantes expresaron
sus opiniones sobre este tema es tan
importante que respetamos el derecho de
las mujeres para tomar sus propias
decisiones sobre la base de sus propias
creencias y circunstancias
pero yo soy cristiana yo veo a mucha
gente que no tiene esperanza y estoy
rezando por ellos
el debate está excento cuando una niña
de 10 años víctima de violación viajo
del estado vecino ohio para terminar su
embarazo a causa de la llamada
prohibición por latido fetal indiana
ahora es el primer estado en aprobar
legislación anti aborto en ambas cámaras
pero en el estado republicano de kansas
la votación se sometió a los residentes
en un referéndum que votaron a favor de
la libertad reproductiva sólo cuatro
estados más incluyendo california
michigan vermot y canto aquí también se
preparan para un voto popular en
noviembre